[Musique]
après une pause de plusieurs mois
les grands ballets sont de retour dans
leur studio pratique un ballet qui est
devenu un bal masqué et un protocole qui
est établi qu est assez stricte mais qui
qui nous permet d'utiliser cet espace
qui était au fait même le costumier
s'est transformé en atelier de masques
ils ont confectionné plus de 700 durant
ces trois mois de pause les danseurs on
continue de s'entraîner de la maison et
en ont profité pour faire un peu
d'introspection
c'était intéressant c'est de voir ce
temps juste pour soi en tant que danseur
parce que le travail d'invention c'est
aussi beaucoup de travail sur soi et
c'était quand même intéressant de voir
cet encens sans autre chose le retour
dans les studios représentait un défi
après des mois sans traîner à l'e3 bien
sûr physiquement doit retourner
graduellement parce qu'après trois mois
c'est sûr mais on fait plus de sauts on
ne peut pas tourner comme on faisait
donc c'est une réadaptation physique les
règles imposées par la santé publique
les force à repenser leur façon de
danser et de travailler ensemble 100 %
de notre travail s'est basé sur
l'échangé humain la proximité physique
après que l'intimité qui crée avec les
gens si son métier très tactile et c'est
un métier où si ou
comme je disais on a des émotions qu'on
doit transmettre imagine si dans ce
roméo et juliette puis tu vas pas la
moitié du visage
c'est super c'est presque ce et
déshumanisant il est trop tôt pour dire
quand les spectacles devant public
pourront reprendre
on a fait tellement des changements
jusqu'à présent au but de moments je me
suis un peu fatigué de faire les
horoscopes de regarder dans les étoiles
dire imaginer plein abcd bien
honnêtement les a tous poussé la
maintenance et concentre sur la forme
sur la reprise sur quelques projets un
peu plus petits comme de captation tout
ce que souhaite la troupe c'est que le
retour à la normale se fasse plus tôt
que tard on se doit de relever le défi
de donner espoir que ça va que savalli
que ça va bien aller et puis quand on va
se retrouver sur 5 le jour on se
retrouvera mais on ne retrouve une
nouvelle façon créer puis on pourra
enfin présenter quelque chose avec
tellement d'émotion je pense que ça va
être historique
magique jeudi passé jusqu'à en attendant
les répétitions et le des confidences
poursuivre un pas à la fois ici nabi
alexandre chartier radio canada montréal
[Musique]